hey everyone its Jesse and today I'm
gonna walk through how to clone a github
repository so I'm gonna start way at the
beginning by installing node and with
that is gonna come come npm node package
manager we're gonna go over how to
install get like your local machine and
then we're gonna actually take a
repository from github we're gonna clone
it onto our machine and we're gonna
install all the packages that we need
and then start it up so that we could
actually see the project on our local
machine and make changes if we want so
let's get started you can see I have a
command line terminal open so I use I
term and I have some custom colors here
so if your terminal doesn't look like
mine don't worry about it it'll still
work so whether you're on Windows Mac or
Linux you know this should work pretty
much the same way I'm on a Mac so my
commands will match up with the Linux
commands there may be some slight
differences on windows so if some of
these commands aren't working check on
what the Windows equivalent of these Mac
commands are so the first thing you want
to do is install node okay this is no
js' it allows you to run server-side
code server-side javascript code okay
you can go to the node.js website and
the the download page will recommend
downloads depending on your system so
the safest bet is to go with the LTS if
you like to live on the eggs and B
you'll have the newest features you
could try to do the the current one but
you know you can download this now there
are other ways to download note on your
machine I'm going over one way to do it
so if you see a different tutorial that
says something different
it doesn't mean it's wrong there there
are just a variety of ways to do it when
we download node this will also come
with node package manager so I'm not
going to download node again but just to
test to make sure that we do have note
on our system we can run node - V and it
tells me the version number of node so
now I know I have node to make sure I
have NPM node package manager on my
system I can also run NPM - V I'm sorry
- - that's not it's not a - it's - V hey
and I have NPM as well okay so after you
go through that process which may take a
while
okay now you're ready to go on to get
now at any point during this process you
if you're on a Mac you may be prompted
to download Xcode download Xcode it
might take a while but you're gonna need
Xcode you're also going to want to make
sure you have the administrator access
to your machine if you don't have admin
access a lot of this probably will not
work so you're gonna have to figure out
you know a way to get administrator
access somehow on a machine so there are
also a variety of ways to install get
locally for me the way I usually use it
seems to be the easiest is to download
the github desktop app and then all your
command-line tools forget will also be
installed it's really easy this is like
download and you you click it and it
it's nice so you don't really have to
have a lot of command line experience so
that's why I'd like it if you want and
you're not really comfortable with the
command line you can even use this
desktop app to do a lot of the things
and get that we're going to do here on
the command line so it's entirely up to
you I've never used the desktop
but the result will be the same whether
you use the command line or the desktop
app so go ahead and download that when
that's finished you can also check to
make sure you have get installed by
saying get V oops okay so the V doesn't
work oh you actually have to type
version okay so we have get installed
now we can get a repository so let's go
to github if you have a github account
you'll see a screen like this I happen
to be using the dark theme for github so
by default you it won't look like this
it'll be a lot lighter it won't have the
black background and everything don't
worry you know works the same way no
matter what the colors are if you don't
have an account you may see a little bit
of a different screen but what we want
to do is navigate to an actual
repository so I've already selected a
repository that I've done and this is
one I I finished up a week or two ago
and you'll see here is a clone or
download button that's where we want to
be all right we want to go to the cloner
download button a good repository will
have some instructions so this one
happens to have instructions to walk you
through how to clone and install it so
that can be very helpful you won't
always see that in a repository though
so what you should do first is click on
this clone or download button and you
want to grab this pass
sorry not password address that's sort
of where I'm thinking of you want to get
this address so you can copy it to your
clipboard now you have to have SSH key
setup for
this to work if you haven't done that
you can just use this link the HTTP link
now we're not going to use these ways
but if you'd like to use that desktop
version you can just open it up right in
the desktop version like this or you can
download the zip file so we're going to
use the ssh version of this on the
command line so let's go back here to
our command line by default your
terminal will put you in your your home
directory I don't like to clone
repositories right to my home directory
it makes things too messy so I create a
directory called projects so let's go
into that so I'm going to CD all right
to change directory and I'm gonna type
projects if if you're new to the command
line you'll notice that I didn't type
the whole thing out a nice trick is just
to type the first few letters of the
directory or file you're looking for and
then hit the tab key and it'll
autocomplete the rest of it so let's hit
enter now I'm in the project's folder if
I do LS it'll show me all the folders in
this projects folder you can see I have
a lot of stuff going on in here so you
can see I'm messy you leggett if I put
all of that in my home directory so
that's why I like to separate it out so
what we want to do now remember we've
copied this so you still have that
copied our clipboard so you want to use
that git command so we're going to say
get space clone we put another space in
there and then we're gonna paste in that
link that we just copied on github and
when we hit enter that whole project now
has been saved so if we do an LS again
we can see that we now have a folder and
that folder is called react seeding
manager so the folder name matches the
project name so if we want to do
anything with the project
we have to remember to actually go into
that folder I've often made the mistake
of starting to work in this projects
folder and not realizing why nothing is
working because I'm not I didn't
actually go into that folder I actually
made that mistake yesterday so it's very
common don't worry if it happens but you
want to make sure you CD right into that
folder so you can see it's not I'm
trying to hit tab and it's not Auto
completing because I have so many things
that start with react it doesn't know
which one I want so I have to type a
little bit more there we are now let's
go into there and if we hit LS and then
give it a flag which means we're gonna
say - and then put a letter in this case
a we can see even the hidden files in
this repository so we're seeing
everything now and we see this dot get
was anything with a dot in front is
normally hidden but that tells us that
this is a gate repository which we
should expect because we just caught it
from github all right but we also have
this package JSON file and that's an
important file so let's take a look at
it before we do anything else and that
package JSON file is going to show us a
lot of what's gonna go on when we go to
install and then run the code that's
here so I'm going to open up this
project in Visual Studio code you can
open it up and whatever editor you like
to use Adam is also another good editor
it's open source from get up visual
studio code is also free there are some
other paid editors like sublime which
which are very good but no matter what
editor you use it'll still get the job
done so I'm gonna type code space and
then a period and that's going to open
up this whole directory in Visual Studio
code now let's maximize
this so we have a little bit more space
and go to that package.json and now I'm
gonna make some more space for us here
and we can see the package.json file is
like instructions to the computer and to
us as the the developers about what this
project is built from and what it can do
so obviously we have named version right
homepage which is nice for this
particular project you you could go and
see an action at the home page we have
the dependencies now these tell the
computer in this case the node package
manager it sells the node package
manager what packages need to be
installed for this project to run
properly and so this is great this is
what allows us to run projects on our
machine and be confident that they're
most likely going to work because we're
getting all the same packages in all the
same versions we don't actually store
all the code for all those packages in
our repository on github that's why
we're able to push code to get up and
download code from github so quickly
because the bulk of the project code is
going to be here in these dependencies
right so by simply including this
package JSON file we're giving all the
instructions that NPM needs to rebuild
this on someone else's computer so the
package is here the the node modules
live on my computer and if you download
it they'll live on your computer but
they'll never go up to github we also
have our scripts now our scripts are
going to tell us what commands we need
to use to run this project so it in this
project we do have
oops we're yet here we go in this
project we do have a readme that gives
instructions on how to run the project
but you won't always have that sometimes
the maintainer is a repository may not
have instructions written out like that
so in that case we can look here and see
what kind of scripts we have so pre
deploy we're not ready for deployment
yeah right we just download this but we
can try this the start right and this
will run react scripts starts our build
is going to get ready for deployment we
don't want to run test yet and we don't
want to eject so pretty safe to assume
if we want to run this locally for
development purposes we're going to use
start ok and in fact that's what it does
say in the readme to use so let's run
the start command the start script and
see what happens whoops before we do
that let's install our packages right I
guess we could try the start script
first let's see what happens when we do
that so we could run npm run start on
newer versions of npm you can leave the
run out so I believe that's optional in
newer versions see look what happen we
got all kind of errors it's looking for
all these packages and we don't have
them all right so now let's run you can
run npm install ok so npm install will
download all those packages there's an
alternative to npm called yarn i happen
to be using yarn on this project if
you're interested in yarn you can read
more about it and choose to download it
if you want it does the same thing as
NPM so I'm gonna run yarn you can run
NPM install if you're following along
and it'll do the same thing for us
so when we hit enter it's gonna get all
those packages and install them and
depending on how large the project is
and how many packages you know this
could take a while you know so if if you
have a slow internet connection or
you're running this on an old computer
you know you may have time to go get a
cup of coffee but in this case it's a
small project on a fast computer of the
fast connection so it's done already
let's go back now and look at what's new
so we can see our folder tree here and
look we have this node modules folder
that was not there before if we take a
peek in here here's a bunch of packages
it's huge right let's close that thing
up because each one of these packages
also has a package.json file with more
packages right so are the bulk of our
projects color load is in this node
modules folder okay so that's why we
have this kid ignore file and this tells
says this is easier all the files that I
want get to ignore and I don't want
these save to github so no modules is
there that would be a whole lot to push
up to github right so now that we have
that let's try to run our start script
again and see what happens this time so
I'm going to hit the up arrow key and
that's going to let me just run through
all the commands that I've recently
typed so this is a big time saver so I'm
going to go back up the NPM run starts
hit enter and let's see what happens all
right so it's telling me something is
already running on port 3000 I happen to
have another project running but that's
not a big deal we can just run on a
different port so I'm going to hit Y and
hit enter to run on a different port now
on my other screen this just opened
okay so this will pop up in your default
browser at localhost 3001 so for you if
you don't have any other projects
running it'll probably be localhost 3000
but we now have this react seeding
manager project and you know we can we
can run it it works it works just like
as if it was on online so if you went to
that URL that's in our package JSON file
you would see the same thing so this is
running it's working but it's running
off of our code here and now we can make
changes so if we go to our our file
let's just changed something very
obvious
where's our title
there we are let's go I'm really excited
about this so let's add three
exclamation points
it gets always a good idea we're going
to save to use either one exclamation
point or three for some reason to just
bothers main ear you are see we've
changed the code we've changed the
program and we see an automatic change
there not every project is going to
automatically change like that it
depends on how the repository owner set
up the project but in this case it
automatically updates so that's it
that's all you need to know to download
a project now there are some projects
that aren't JavaScript based you may
need some other things for that but a
lot of projects on github are javascript
praise so if your web developer you're
most likely going to be doing something
similar to this maybe in another video
we'll cover what to do next like that
made changes now what okay
but for now you should know everything
you need to know to pull down a
repository quick recap before we before
we go step one make sure you have node
installed on your machine
step two annal so node comes with NPM so
it's not a separate install step two
make sure you have git installed on your
machine right we used github desktop app
to kind of do the installation for us
and then step three is find a repository
on github and get that clone link okay
when you do that you can run git clone
paste the link in and now you have the
repository if there are instructions in
the readme read over those first and
follow those the project may have some
extra steps you need to do so if a
project readme varies from what I've
said in this video go with that
particular projects instructions so
let me know if this video was helpful if
I messed up anything or there's
something else that you'd like me to
cover if if this is helpful to you I'd
love to do more videos so please let me
know if you like it that's awesome if
you know you could like the video but
really I love feedback so you know let
me know in the comments what you think
and hopefully I'll be back soon with
another video and be sure to check out
my live streams on the free code can't
YouTube channel as well have a great day
and I'll see it